hey remember that Nazi linked Trump
advisor Sebastian Gorka you remember him
right Pat oh he's one of my favorites
he's one of the most smug trumpets
absolutely no doubt about it he was
ousted from the Trump administration
when chief of staff John Kelly the
elegant John Kelly as I call him showed
up and realized that Gorka had to go and
scare Moochie had to go and Steven
Bannon had to go Gorka left okay I've
previously told you about his ties to a
Hungarian Nazi Party and I've also
previously told you that immediately
upon his release from the Trump
administration Fox News immediately
hired him which kind of made perfect
sense things are not going so well for
Sebastian Gorka Hungarian police have an
active warrant out for his arrest he's
reportedly in trouble with the law over
firearm or ammunition abuse that's
that's part one right but here's the
real stunner the warrant dates all the
way back to September of 2016 that means
that not only has Gorka been avoiding
justice for more than a year when Trump
hired him the warrant was already out
for his arrest this is the guy who said
he would hire the best people and he was
in favor of extreme betting how minimal
was your vetting to not have realized
your own staffer has a warrant out for
their arrest he was working for seven
months for the President of the United
States and he was wanted for arrest in
another country
BuzzFeed reached out to Gorica for
comment he told them don't waste your
time I don't talk to BuzzFeed BuzzFeed
published the story and then Gorka took
to Twitter where he said did Glenn
referring to Glenn Kessler from The
Washington Post did Glenn and BuzzFeed
get a fakey award from real Donald Trump
they should quote an incident from 2009
oh really I moved to America in 2008
legally try facts next time Glenn hack
so two things to notice from this tweet
number one
Gorka doesn't deny that the warrant
exists that's a very very important
point
and number two he says he moved to the
United States before the incident for
which Hungary wants him arrested I moved
to the United States from Argentina in
1989 does that mean that there couldn't
be a warrant out for my arrest in
Argentina from 1992 if I had gone back
in 92 and committed a crime or was
suspected of one what what relevance
does the year I moved have anything to
do with it and I in fact I think there
is one but we won't talk about that
yeah well by the way when I was not in
1992 when I was 8 years old I was
actually accused of multiple crimes in
Argentina and they all related to steak
that I can assure you
very strange defense from Gorka but for
me the funniest part is he wasn't vetted
by Trump who says he wants extreme
vetting of immigrants report indicate
that if they had done a simple
background check it would have turned up
that he had an international you know a
foreign a warrant out for his arrest
which suggests that Trump is not doing
the vetting and is this really the
example of the the best person to hire
Trump said he would hire the best people
he hired an unvetted allegedly criminal
immigrant but not to like do work and
put in windows at one of his real estate
projects he had this guy working at the
White House yeah and Donald Trump is
supposed to be the law and order Canada
- and the US and hungry have an
extradition treaty so I'm sure that
Sebastian Gorka will be on the next
flight back oh I'm absolutely sure yeah
he's gonna be back at Trump first thing
Trump's gonna do is get this guy
extradited I have to hurt hungry don't
hold your breath
pathetic discuss this with us on our
subreddit at david pakman.com slash read
it we'll take a break and be back after
this today's sponsor is zip recruiter
it's a new year if you're setting new
goals for your business I know that we
are it's extremely difficult to reach
them without the right people on your
team and zip recruiter has transformed
how you go about finding those people
zip recruiter posts your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
with just a single click and then zip
recruiter actively looks for the most
qualified candidates and invites them to
apply they even review every application
to identify the top candidates so you
never have to miss a great match no
wonder that 80% of employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day
zip recruiter is the smartest way to
hire and you can find out why zip
recruiter has been used by businesses of
all sizes and industries to find the
most qualified job candidates with
immediate results and right now my
listeners can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free that's right for free if you go
to zip recruiter comm slash Pakman
that's zip recruiter com forward slash
PA que ma and one more time zip
recruiter dot-com slash Pakman